[تصفيق
] رئيس كوبا ميغيل
دياز كانيل هو الآن
أيضًا أول رئيس للحزب الشيوعي القوي في الجزيرة
منذ الثورة ،
تم اختيار قناة كاسترو دياز
يوم الاثنين كسكرتير أول في مؤتمر
مغلق
للشيوعي الكوبي
الحزب السياسي الوحيد المسموح به في الجزيرة
بعد أن قال راؤول كاسترو إنه سيتقاعد
إذا لم ينه نفوذه تمامًا
، فسيتم استشارته بشأن
أهم القرارات الإستراتيجية
التي تؤثر على أمتنا ، وقال دياز كانيل
عن سلفه
في 61 دياز كانيل إنه أصغر بكثير  من
أولئك الذين يبلغون من العمر 80 و 90 عامًا والذين قاتلوا إلى جانب
فيدل
كاسترو ومنذ الثورة احتلوا
معظم المناصب العليا في كوبا ، يقول
المسؤولون الأمريكيون الذين التقوا دياز كانيل
في حين أنه من غير المرجح أن يلقي محاضرات حول شرور الإمبريالية من
كاسترو.
إنه مؤمن بشدة بالنظام الذي أنشأوه
حقًا للمضي قدمًا
ولتنفيذ نوع الإصلاحات التي ستحتاج كوبا
لسنها يجب عليهم التحرك  فيما وراء
الكاستروس ، بينما يتوقع القليل من
المسؤولين الأصغر سناً مثل دياز كانيل
الذي اختاره رال كاسترو
أن ينحرف عن خط الحزب ، فإن
رمزية كوبا بدون
كاستروس رسميًا هي أمر مذهل بالنسبة لمعظم
الكوبيين الذين ولدوا بعد ثورة 1959
وحتى وقت قريب.  لم يعرفوا سوى
كاسترو على رأس بلدهم
الآن بعد أن بدأت هذه العائلة الشهيرة التي
أثرت على كوبا
بشدة في التخلي عن
السلطة ، يصبح السؤال هو
ما إذا كانت ثورة كاسترو يمكن أن
تستمر بدونهم على
الرغم من حقن دماء جديدة
في القمة
تكافح الحكومة الكوبية للتكيف مع الأوقات التي
يستخدم فيها النقاد في الجزيرة
إمكانية الوصول المتزايد إلى الإنترنت لإظهار ما يقولون
إنه الفقر المتزايد والظلم ، وقد أدى
الاقتصاد الذي
دمره كوفيد إلى ظهور
طوابير أطول وأطول للحصول على الطعام
، حيث فرضت الإدارة الرابحة بعضًا
من أشد العقوبات صرامة  في كوبا
في العقود التي يبدو أن الرئيس بايدن حتى الآن
متردد في رفعها عندما
أعلن تقاعده
رال كاسترو  قال إنه سيترك السلطة لكنه
لم يتخلَّ عن معركته الطويلة ،
سأستمر في اللحام بصفتي
مقاتلًا ثوريًا آخر يقول إنه
مستعد لتقديم مساهمتي المتواضعة
حتى نهاية حياتي ،
لكن كاسترو سيبلغ التسعين في يونيو عندما
كان شقيقه فيدل
مات وفي شرق كوبا
بنى كاسترو بالفعل مقبرة لنفسه
بجوار قبر زوجته التي توفيت
في عام 2007.
مستقبل كوبا غير مؤكد لكن عصر
حكم كاسترو
الطويل المستمر يقترب من نهايته
باتريك جوتمان سي إن هافانا